[Music]
listen newly released body camera video
shows what led up to an officer-involved
shooting after the suspect charged at
police armed with multiple nines hey hey
stay right here bro stay right here
got two knives
tell us we're gonna die it happened on
February 5th in Aurora Illinois just
after 10 o'clock that morning dispatch
received a 9-1-1 call for a man armed
with multiple knives what's going on
I have uh young people fighting and
older people trying to stop them
I've got a young grandson here who him
and his girlfriend are fighting over a
baby
the dad is trying to stop them is
getting violent
and before the violence happens I need
somebody to remove physical or verbal
it's it could be physical any moment the
caller told dispatch her grandson later
identified as 21 year old Christopher
Cross was armed with knives from her
kitchen she said cross was in a verbal
argument that could soon become physical
who's holding them back
tonight
he's got a knife
several he has several
he has more than one yes I think it's
three is he threatening anybody with him
yes everybody what is he saying
he will kill them he will kill us and he
will die today
the police will have to shoot him when
Aurora police officers arrived they
found cross at the front door holding
two knives in his hands
drop the knife
Put The Knife down now Knife Down dude
Put The Knife Down yeah Put The Knife
Down body camera video shows officers
repeatedly asked cross to drop the
weapons he can be heard threatening
officers saying that they will die
Hey listen dude we're here to help man
I'm here to help you
buddy buddy what's your name
buddy what's your name
as officers ask cross to drop the knives
he can be seen slamming them together
what is your name can everybody get out
of the house
after that cross again threatens the
officers before slamming the door in
their faces
[Music]
listen hey hey stay over here bro stay
right here
he's got two knives
tell us we're gonna die today that's
when officers check with cross's
Grandmother to make sure everyone is
outside of the home except for cross we
have four subjects a child
grandma and mom are out of the house
there's one other male in the house
apparently in the shower minutes later
cross appears still armed with knives in
hand why don't you just drop the knife
bud
hey stay back stay back
stay back video shows officers shooting
cross with pepper balls in an attempt to
stop him instead he charges at officers
that's when shots ring out
drop the knife
after cross is shot officers immediately
begin to perform life-saving measures
[Applause]
[Music]
while treating cross officers find a
third knife on him another can be seen
near his ankle as he charges toward
police body camera video shows officers
handcuffing cross which Aurora Police
say is normal protocol after that they
apply a chest seal and tourniquet in an
effort to stop the bleeding
hello
two other shots to the legs
emergency responders arrive shortly
after and take across to the hospital
officials say he was seriously injured
in the shooting but have not given more
specifics about his condition right now
the shooting is still under
investigation cross now faces multiple
charges including two counts of
attempted murder and aggravated assault
with a deadly weapon reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie